express 25 degrees celsius as a
temperature in degrees fahrenheit using
the formula fahrenheit or f is equal to
nine-fifths times the celsius degrees
plus 32. so they're telling us that we
have 25 degrees celsius so we could put
that in 4c here and we'll get the
temperature in fahrenheit degrees so
let's do that so we'll get f
is equal to 9 over 5
times now for c we're going to put in 25
times 25 plus
and now we can simplify this before we
multiply 25 times nine remember this is
the same thing as nine fifths times 25
over one we can essentially divide the
numerator and the denominator of our
eventual product by five if we divide 25
by five we get five if we divide five by
five we get one so this boils down to
nine times five plus thirty-two
so our fahrenheit degrees are going to
be 9 times 5 is 45
plus 32 degrees
or it's equal to 45 plus 32 is 77 so
this is 77
degrees fahrenheit